[Music]
[Applause]
you know
it didn't have to be this way
the micro cosmos is vast and there are
so many organisms meeting and
interacting with each other every day
and things often go very well for the
microbes we watch
they often live peaceful lives that do
not end with them being
gruesomely turned into the external
stomach of a single-celled parasite heck
we could even be talking about the
ciliate up on the screen right now
called the nasula
only we could have gone back to when it
looked more like this the inside of its
body dripping with blue yellow and black
and we could have been sitting here
talking about how nasal has swim through
clouds of plankton seeking out their
next meal of cyanobacteria and how after
the nasula capture and digest their prey
their cytoplasm fills with the colors
that once belonged to the cyanobacteria
beads of blue and blobs of yellow and
sometimes even bits of pink
a colorful casualty of consumption
but no we are not here today to talk
about cyanobacteria and pigments
we have other matters to discuss
because somewhere else in the micro
cosmos
is this
i know it might not look like much
just a pill with a vacuole opening and
closing inside it while little tufts of
hair move on the surface
this
is a suctorian a type of ciliate which
makes it a relative of the nasula
but this is a young saktorian a larvae
eventually the sakturian will shed its
rings of cilia and in the process it
will lose both its family resemblance
and its ability to swim around
but that's not a concern for the
saktorian the ciliate that should be
more worried is the nasula because a
hairless sactorian doesn't stay bald it
replaces its cilia with tentacles
and this
is what happens next
[Music]
remember the saktorian can't swim
anymore
it can't go seek a silliet but it can
sit around with its tentacles extended
waiting for the right cilia to come to
it
and when one does
the tentacles go to work sticking to and
sinking into its target
in the area around where the saktorian's
tentacles have attached the nacila's
cilia will stop beating
but it's just a small portion of the
cilia for now not enough to stop it
entirely and so for a time the nacilla
will continue swimming
seemingly unaware of the suctory and on
its back
for the saktorian this is a good deal it
doesn't need to swim anymore it has
nasality to do that
but nasula is more than just a free ride
around the micro cosmos
it is also the saktorians next meal
[Music]
sometimes we are what we eat and
sometimes we are what's eating us
and with the saktorian attached the
nasula becomes more and more difficult
to recognize looking more and more like
a whale without sized barnacles
protruding from its side
near the site where they have attached
to the nasula the suctorian will begin
to digest bits of their host
this means that the nasula now has three
uses for the saktorian a free ride a
meal and now
a temporary external stomach
like the cilia that stopped beating this
digestion is localized allowing the
nasula's organelles to contract in the
organism to live as it is slowly being
digested
from within the suctorian does not have
an oral cavity to act as a mouth but it
doesn't need one it has tentacles which
shorten in length and thicken in width
as the suctorian begins to pass grains
of the digested ciliate through it
and the nasula once kaleidoscopic with
the remains of its own meals
will now pass those colors onto its
unwelcome passenger
for some suctorians one host is not
enough to satiate its appetite if you
look at the top corner of the nasula
here you can see that one of the
suctoria has its tentacles poking
outwards keeping them extended and ready
in case another national comes along to
add to its meal
and this is not a matter of moving from
one host to the next
no the saktorian is happy to attach
itself
to multiple nasula assembling a crowd of
hosts and parasites
but the saktorian has one more use left
for its host
a nest
not a real nest of course suctorians
don't lay eggs instead
they bud growing their young out of
themselves and they do this while
attached to their host sprouting their
young on the outside of their non-motile
bodies until the new larvae is ready for
life on its own
the baby suctorian is equipped with its
own cilia able to swim away for its own
independent life but at the end of the
day suctorians are parasites they are
not meant to be on their own so
one day when they are ready those larvae
will follow the path of their parent
settling down for a life
on their own meal
it didn't have to be this way of course
the nasula could have lived its whole
life without ever having come across a
sactorian parasite it could have spent
its life contentedly grazing upon
cyanobacteria
and converting itself into a
multicolored monument to its own meals
and many nacilla have lived such lives
meeting their ends in other ways perhaps
more dramatic perhaps less
but our world is maintained by these
meetings
by these pigments these chemicals this
energy passing from one organism to the
next
and by the fateful contact of some
patient
outstretched tentacles
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you of
course for
all of the support you have shown this
channel over the past two years that it
has existed whether that's been through
sharing videos with friends and family
or supporting the channel directly by
being a patron on patreon or by picking
up some of our micro cosmos merch like
our new tardigrade shirt again that
pre-order runs only through august 31st
so if you want to make sure you get the
color you want before one of them goes
away forever you will have to order
before the end of the month over at
dftba.com
this episode it marks the end of season
four of journey to the micro cosmos but
we will be back with season five and
speaking of the aforementioned patreon
patrons you are now seeing their names
on the screen
if you like what we do here and you want
to thank us for this show existing these
are the people that you should be
thanking we appreciate all of them so
much and if you would like to join them
you can head on over to patreon.com
journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram and if you want
to see more from us there's probably a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you